Oh
mostly I mean we don't get very much
time to let go around to other YouTube
channels and another problem is like no
one does what we do so it's not like we
have very many buddies in arms we can go
and comment on so I mean in terms of
talking to our own channels we
absolutely you know we we read our
comments if it feels like it needs a
response we will absolutely respond to
it if it's a troll will either ignore it
or sometimes will you know use the I'm a
nice person and I'll give you a nice
response to your trolling and often
times that will kind of subdue the troll
so you know we do try to keep our kippah
an idea on what's going on on our own
channel and will try to respond all of
our messages and stuff so yeah we try to
keep our community active but in terms
of reaching out to the rest of the
community it's a little it's a lot
harder to do that sometimes
channels that we contact us we looked at
contact back yes always and the other
groups that we contact our people we
needed things like this where will
regulate will interview people kind of
like this and we'll try to keep in touch
of them afterwards and say hey you know
we met you with blah blah blah what's
going on so those are the two groups of
like youtubers intend to go find
actually
what do you think
yeah that those exist
didn't eat their vegetables as a child
but okay it's the primary bro we
actually talking about this like a
couple hours ago and I feel like that I
mean they're just legitimately angry
people which is kind of sad but you know
when you're when all you do is yell at
yell at people are or call them the
dirty names that I can't say because
we're a kid from the channel you know
when people are doing that a lot of time
it's that they're legitimately hurt
people and I mean I can imagine that if
I was a really angry human being I would
want to yell at people everywhere I
found so it's you know it's annoying but
it's also kind of sad on their part i
feel kind of stuff it's not sorry for
them because it's like find a better
outlook on life so I feel like it's
harsh partially almost legitimate in
terms of just heart angered stuff wil
wheaton agrees
you